[Music]
travis barker is clapping back at an
internet troll making fun of his pda
with kourtney kardashian they are so
happy
seem so in love
and never stop making out by the way
like ever
over the weekend after sharing photos of
himself working out a user hits up the
drummer's comment section and
sarcastically asks no kardashian finger
up the app
tongue intestines nudity pda etc etc
anymore slacking travis fires back with
a cheeky response writing still got the
finger up the app and my intestines were
totally nude and full pda with my fiance
adding a middle finger emoji i'm just
like living life and
whatever happens happens it's no secret
the couple loves a pda moment
[Music]
yeah there they are being all
lovey-dovey at the grammys
and there's plenty more of that just
check out kravis at the oscars
[Music]
all over social media
[Music]
and all that romance well you can expect
to see it on the family's new reality
show on hulu the kardashians are you
sticking to the table
i see you
feel it
i'm not sure courtney really has a type
but
if she does
it's definitely travis like i've watched
them
come to a decision over something as
simple as a dessert
you probably won't find me straddling
corey every five minutes yeah and during
a recent appearance on ellen momager
kris jenner doubled down on all of that
travis and and courtney for real just
make out non-stop that's all they do
well it is 98 of the new show it's a
beautiful thing to the beginning of
court and travis's relationship like the
details on the lovebirds first date who
went in for the first kiss me
i did
he was taking a long time the movie was
over and then i was like we started
another movie and i was like i don't
have time for this like movie marathon
so i made the first move also on the
show the pair's engagement one of the
biggest things in her life is about to
happen and courtney has no idea
travis popped the question back in
october and earlier this month they said
i do in an unofficial las vegas ceremony
officiated by who else an elvis
impersonator you did a practice run on
the wedding congratulations yeah so
thank you when is the real wedding and
what will that look like because we're
really seeing your love story with your
soul mate on the new show you are we
don't know yet we're just living our
best lives a source told e.t back in
january the couple is planning an
intimate and special celebration quote
they want their wedding to speak on
behalf of both of their styles with some
sexiness and elegance
both courtney and travis are so looking
forward to spending the rest of their
lives together as soul mates
the second we
fell in love i think we knew how
different it was from anything
either of us have ever had before and so
i think that you know we absolutely see
a future together
[Music]